Hey Nick, I have a question for you. So if I'm searching some, I've had this question a lot,
so people are searching their keywords. Three of them are under $5, but then you get one that's
like $10. What is your thoughts? Do you still go into that or do you? If it's your first deal, no.
Okay, first deal? If it's your first deal, no. If it's your first, second, third deal,
no. You want to follow it exactly. Even if there's one keyword that's creeping above,
you're still going to run into problems. Now, why does it change if it's your third, fourth,
fifth deal? Because now let's say it's your sixth deal, Porter, you know that, hey,
in order for this to work, the CPC on that one keyword is double. I'm going to have to charge
a minimum of like $2,000 to make the numbers work, right? But when it's your first deal,
sometimes getting that $2,000 deal is a huge obstacle because you're like not used to asking
for $2,000. Okay? So no, I'm saying stick to it exactly on your first few deals,
and that's where you're going to find the goal. Cool.